je suis innocent à 100 % je suis victime
d' d'abominale machination je suis le
Bouère
[Musique]
idéal
Tommy condamné à perpétuité en 1960 pour
un
meurtre il est sorti au bout de 17 ans 2
ans après sa libération il a de nouveau
tué cette fois-ci si
personnes si la peine de mort avait
encore existé en 83 il était il était
bon
il est mécaniquement criminel le mot
mort pour lui ce n'est qu'un mot au
total Tommy a passé plus d'un
demi-siècle en prison aujourd'hui il ne
souhaite plus qu'une seule chose finir
sa vie libre est-ce que quand il va
sortir il aura pas une idée de
vengeance estil encore dangereux doit-il
rester en prison jusqu'à la fin de ses
jours je suis dans un état de révolte je
passe pas une journée ça passit à lui
avec Imen guali nous avons décidé de
retrouver les protagonistes de l'affaire
Ro et d'analyser avec eux les
conséquences et les répercussions de ce
dossier hors
norme verdict sans surprise hier soir à
Draguignan le juris de la Cour d'Assise
du Var a condamné Tommy RCO à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité pour
les deux triples meurtres de carqueran
et de
Bézier ce vendredi soir après sa journée
de travail madame logof rentre chez elle
à carkerane dans le
Var à son arrivée les gendarmes sont
déjà sur
place son mari Sandrine sa fille de 11
ans viennent d'être
[Musique]
tué leur voisin Jacques coutrick est
également retrouvé mort les trois
victime ont été froidement exécuté
elles ont été abatttues d'une balle dans
la nuque hein il y a pas eu de de de de
de lutte donc c'est vraiment un un un un
assassinat de sang frroid perpétré par
un individu qui n'a pas peur de tuer on
pourrait même dire c'est un assassinat
commis par un
habitué pourquoi un tel carnage et qui
se cache derrière ces
crimes les gendarmes découvrent que le
soir du meurtre la petite Cendrine a
essayé de joindre sa mère au centre pour
enfant où elle travaille
elle dit quelqu'un veut faire du mal à
mon papa
c'est le cousin de René au
secours c'est à partir de cette
précision que les gendarmes vont tenter
de mettre un nom sous l'appellation le
cousin de René et ils vont chercher dans
l'entourage des victimes trois René on
va vite en éliminer deux qui ont des
alibi et le seul qui nous reste du
cousin de René c'est le nommé Tommy
ro Joseph Thomas RCO dit
Tommy il a 45 ans est originaire de
Corse et a un passé pour le moins
inquiétant en 1960 R a déjà commis un
meurtre pour lequel il a purgé une
longue peine de
prison la victime était un proche de la
famille son parrain garde maritime à
Propriano quelques jours après les faits
Tommy avait été dénoncé pour ce crime
par son propre frère
Pierre il dit qu'il se trouvait avec lui
sur le
bateau qu'ils étaient en train de pêcher
à dynamite enfin le braconnet et et que
y s'est rendu compte que depuis la rive
le garde pêche était là qui les
[Musique]
observait le fait que le corps est été
littéralement massacré après avoir été
criblé de de ball ou de chevrtine et
bien ajoua bien sûr à la dramatisation
de cette affaire il y avait eu comme un
[Musique]
acharnement maître Alain laode pourquoi
tomyo ce 28 octobre 1960 sur une plage
de Propriano aurait-il tué son parrain
manifestement il ne supporte pas euh
d'être surpris et il va décider de
supprimer cet homme mais reconit ce
meurtre il a toujours contesté ce
meurtre ça n'a pas trompé la cour
d'assise à l'époque puisque il a échappé
de peu à la peine capitale qu'il a été
condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité avant de bénéficier plus tard
d'une libération conditionnelle pourquoi
cette libération conditionnelle il fait
end comportement exemplaire en
détention chef de la corale à
clairau intervenant lorsque des
mouvements divers se font au sein de la
détention protégeant les surveillants
d'administration
pénitentiaire c'est ainsi que cette
demande de libération conditionnelle
après 17 ans sera
acceptée un comportement exemplaire en
prison oui mais mur la réputation de
Tommy R n'est pas si
noble c'est quelqu'un dont tout le monde
sait qu'il vaut mieux ne pas avoir de
discussion passionné de d'échange de
mots de contrariété réciproque avec lui
tout le monde se doute que la réponse ne
peut être qu'une réponse violente de sa
part un profil qui colle donc avec le
triple meurtre de
carkeran les gendarmes interrogent Tommy
rou mais le corps se ni fermement le
jour du meurtre il était à Marseille
c'est là qu'il travaille dans une
entreprise spécialisée dans le matériel
de
plongée Tommy ro aurait donc un alibi
mais les gendarmes ne le lâchent pas
pour autant je lui ai parlé je dit
pourquoi tu vous avez fait ça ou
n'importe il me répondait pas là j'avais
un journal à côté de moi et où il y
avait la photo de la petite fille et là
je lui ai montré j'ai dit mais pourquoi
vous avez fait ça ro persiste il n'a
rien fait les enquêteurs décident alors
d'entendre une des cousine de Tommy pour
vérifier son
alipie et quand il l'avait passé il m'a
dit pourquoi ma cousine est là et ben
j'ai dit ma fois c'est de ta faute tu
avais qu'à pas faire ce que tu as fait
et il là il a il a eu un mouvement de de
recul puis il m'a dit à toi je vais te
le
dire mais il m'a dit je veux pas que tu
prennes la machine à écrire ça me fait
mal à la
tête Tomy se met à table il avait dit-il
ind différent avec Monsieur
legof il est venu pour le voir pour
s'expliquer ça a dégénéré le coup de feu
est parti
il Racon ça
comme je sais pas comme quelqu'un qui
raconte une histoire
banale on avait l'impression que se rend
paste de ce qui
[Musique]
faisit il m'a dit moi quand je veux tuer
quelqu'un je tire dans la tête
et quand je veux le faire souffir je
tire dans les
genoux on na jamais su véritablement
quelles étaient les relations entre
Tommy RCO et Monsieur legof il se serait
disputé à propos d'une arme il aurait
perdu la tête il l'aurait abattu ce
malheureux monsieur coutrix qui était un
voisin il perd la vie et puis
cette
gamine est abattu d'une balle dans la
tête donc il présente les choses si vous
voulez
comme le fait que cette dispute dégénère
il peut pas laisser de témoins et donc
il abat tout le monde Tommy ro dit qu'on
lui a extorqué ses aveux à l'époque il
prétendait avoir été frappé sodomisé
même avec un un manche à Balet
l'expertise médicale n'apportera pas la
démonstration qu'il a été effectivement
victime de violence lors de sa garde à
vue mais en tout cas il va ensuite
camper sur cette position vous êtes son
conseil est-ce qu'à ce moment-là vous
essayez de lui faire entendre raison le
problème c'était d'essayer de lui faire
comprendre
et lui dire en réalité que les charges
étaient accablantes et que s'il les
reconnaissait ben
il ferait un pas vers la communauté des
hommes quand même hein et qu'il devait
ça au moins victimes
euh j'avoue que sur ce terrainlà j'ai
échoué des victimes les enquêteurs vont
découvrir que Tommy ro en a fait
d'autres c'était 3 semaines plus tôt à
300 km de là dans la région de
Bézier ce 22 décembre
1979 joseette Alcaraz devait déjeuner
chez ses parents
[Musique]
elle devait finir à midi et puis elle me
téléphone à 10h30 c'est son dernier coup
de film Maman je te téléphone parce que
ne m'attendis pas pour manger avec Papa
parce que il y a trop de travail veille
de Noël il faut que je reste plus
longtemps je sais pas quelle heure je
rentrerai dans l'après-midi voilà c'est
ses dernières
paroles vers 13
dans le supermarché où travaille Josette
Alcaraz un braquage
éclate je monte au vestière et j'ai une
collègue Roseline qui m'arrête et tout
àolé me dit carain il est arrivé un
drame il est arrivé un drame je lui dis
mais écoute pourquoi tu me dis ça elle
me dit je te promets il y a un hold up
il y a eu un hold
[Musique]
up on rentre et là on fait la découverte
du drame c'està-dire que on passe le sas
les deux portes du
sas on voit un premier corps allongé
face
contreterre et sur la gauche deux autres
corps des deux autres filles qui
travaillaient à Sal des
coffres Jose Alcaras René chamaillou et
syvette Morel ont été lâchement
exécutés elle n'avait pas 30
ans c'est carrément une tuerie parce que
les trois filles les trois caissières
ont pris chacune une balle dans la tête
alors qu'elles étaient allongées par
terre c'est une exécution pur et simple
avec un gros calibre en
plus on s'aperçoit que que le tueur n'a
pas hésité à les abattre foidement alors
qu'il était pas obligé
hein
mais bon peut-être que l'une d'entre
elles le connaissait et c'est peut-être
pour ça qui les a tué toutes les trois
ou parce que il aurait pu être
éventuellement
[Musique]
reconnu Guy Morel votre épouse avait 27
ans ou comment avez-vous appris sa mort
ah ben tout simplement ce sont des amis
à moi qui sont venus et ils m'ont dit
tout simplement il faut que tu viennes
avec nous puisque ta femme veut te voir
je suis parti à baziier et je suis aller
bien sûr au magasin mammouth et quand je
suis arrivé disons au niveau du
supermarché il y avait une efférescence
j'ai vu qu'il y avait des girophare qui
qui avait les pompiers qui avait la
police et bien sûr j'esseréen comprendre
mais on a fait fait que me dire aller à
l'hôpital elles sont à l'hôpital mais
j'en savais pas plus et quand j'arrivéis
à l'hôpital il y avait des infirmier
infirmièrees monsieur Morel venez on va
vous calmer j'ai pas besoin de calmage
j'ai besoin de rien mais personne ne
nous a donné la moindre information et
c'est le lundi que j'ai été avisé par le
procureur de la République de me rendre
le le soir à 19h à baisier à la morue
parlez-nous de Sylvette quel genre de
femme c'était ah ben écoutez pour moi
c'était c'était la plus belle femme que
j'ai pu rencontrer puisque on était
adolescent on a fait notre jeunesse
ensemble il y avait aucune animosité
aucun problème c'était l'entente
parfaite et du jour au lendemain vous
vous retrouvez seul avec votre petite
avec votre petite fille de 6 ans
qu'est-ce que vous voulez moi le premier
je ne pouvais pas m'en occuper parce que
moi tous les jours il fallait que
j'aille mon travail et ma fille est
resta avec sa grand-mère et on a vitcu
avec ce drama qu'il fallait assumer
quoi
des familles de victimes qui se
retrouvent seul face à leur douleur seul
aussi face à celui qu'ell tiennent en
partie pour responsable du drame le
directeur du magasin et ben le directeur
est venu me trouver en me disant que
pour lui il considérait pas ça comme un
accident de travail parce que c'est une
personne étrangère au mamouth qui les
avait tué que c'était pas le plafond qui
leur est tombé sur la tête après alors
je je lui répondu que si c'était pour me
dire ça qu'il était venu qu'il pouvait
repartir le directeur il voulait bientôt
m'intimider tout je vous assure je l'ai
pris on était à un étage j'ai cru que je
le jetais dans l' enas il voulait pas
prendre en
considération les risques qu'il avait
fait prendre au personnel mais
malheureusement c'était trop tard après
on a reçu quelques temps après des
feuilles de paye et effectivement sur
cette feuille de paye le salaire était
arrêté au 22
1979 à
1h moment du drame ils n'ont même pas
terminé le mois bon l'argent c'est c'est
secondaire si on veut mais c'est la
façon c'est le procédé c'est
pas VO ça ça m'a
complètement
[Musique]
retourné si les familles des victimes
peineent à faire leur deuil l'enquête
elle progresse les deux triples meurtres
de an béier semble porter la signature
d'un seul et même
meurtrier dans les deux cas le tuur n'a
laissé aucun témoin il a utilisé le même
mode opératoire et les expertises
balistiques
[Musique]
correspondent Joseph Tommy RCO a été
inculpé pour le triple assassinat commis
au supermarché mammou de Bézier le 22
décembre dernier une inculpation qui
s'ajoute à celle du triple meurtre de
carkereran le 18 janvier Joseph tomierco
a 45 ans il est donc soupçonné et accusé
du meurtre de 6
personnes malgré les évidence r reste
fidèle à lui-même et tente d'échapper à
la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
justice maître lotte concernant le
triple meurtre du supermarché de Bézier
comment s'explique votre client il va
arriver chez le juge d'instruction de
Bézier en niant complètement je n'ai
absolument rien Ren à voir avec cette
histoire je suis innocent à 100 % sauf
que bien évidemment l'information va
démontrer que il effectue des livraisons
dans divers supermarchés de la région
donc dans ce supermarché et que
l'accusation démontrera que grâce à un
stratagème il a eu accès à la salle des
coffres il va être mis en cause par un
témoin qui va le reconnaître à son
regard qui est particulier qui est très
bleu qui est classial et ça va rester
gravé dans la mémoire de cet
homme des éléments à charge même si
l'arme du crime reste toujours
introuvable le combat de la défense à
partir de ce moment-là consistait à dire
c'est peut-être la même arme mais est-ce
que c'est le même tireur une arme au
niveau du milieu ça peut passer de main
en main et on ne peut quand même pas
affirmer avec certitude que c'était le
même tireur qui a utilisé l'arme et à
baisier et à
carkeran pourtant tout le monde
considère tomir comme un dangereux
criminel il est ce que les Américains
commencent tout juste à appeler à
l'époque un serial
killer on a effectivement le coupable
idéal fa être clair on a
quelqu'un qui a un lourd Passier
judiciaire et effectivement très vite
Tommy ro ne va plus être présenté comme
un assassin présumé il va être carrément
étant donné le poid de l'émotion qu'on
provoqué ces deux affaires être présenté
dans la presse souvent comme un assassin
qu'on a déjà jugé et
condamné l'ambiance est explosive quand
s'ouvre le procès de Tommy ro en juin
1983 on sent que les gens sont énervés
ils auraient bien aimé que la peine de
mort existe
[Musique]
encore quand le fourgon arrive il me
semble souvenir qu'ils ont crié à mort
il me semble bien
j'ai gardé ce souvenir juste avant
d'entrée je lui dit bon monsieur ro
essayer quand même de d'être modéré de
de ah non ils vont m'entendrein je vais
faire le show je vais faire le
spectacle et alors le r lui il a créé
aussi une atmosphère absolument
invraisemblable il est arrivé avec sa
chevelure cravate et il y en a il
faisait des gestes disant je suis
Jésus-Christ je suis innocent comme
Jésus je suis innocent à 100 % je suis
victime machination je suis leère ID ce
à quoi quelqu'un dans la salle lui
répond et tu es coupable comme Satan il
entre dans ce box là propulsé par une
force presque surhumaine avec une petite
pochette en plastique l'index levé ici
je suis victime d'abominable machination
on n'est pas chez Pinochet on n'est pas
au Chili j'ai V vraiment le chemin de la
croix je suis innocent vraiment à 100
%. notez messieurs de la presse notez
donc c'est comportement assez
exceptionnel chez un
accusé au-delà de ce triste spectacle le
procès de tomir est placé sous haute
sécurité on pouvait très très bien
supposer qu'un qu'un homme comme
Monsieur Morel qui était au dans le dans
le fin fond du gouffre du chagrin euh
pouvait se se foutrait perdument de ce
qui allait lui arriver et descendre
Tommy ro c'est certain que qu'il avait
une crainte de ce côté
là qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse
moi je vous dis je pouvais pas bouger
j'avais la police sur moi le moindre
geste que je
faisais j'étais neutralisé en quelque
sorte comment est-ce que vous auriez
aimé qu'il se comporte qu'est-ce que
vous auriez aimé qu'il puisse vous
dire déjà la première des choses c'est
qu'il reconnaissent ses actes
[Musique]
c'était très difficile pour les partis
civiles supporter ça parce que rogit il
aurait reconnu les fait peut-être ça
aurait été plus logique pour les les
parties civiles pour les parents des
victimes ils auraient compris mais là
cette comédie de l'innocence qui éit
absolument invraisemblable ça les rend
des fou vous et les avocats de la
défense vous allez le supplier de dire
la vérité est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment qu'il va vous écouter j'ai eu
le sentiment à un moment donné que il
pouvait céder à la pression de cette
audience c'est une audience qui charit
une violence extrême de la douleur de
ses malheureuses victimes une tension
permanente et j'ai eu pendant quelques
secondes le sentiment
que que que que la machine allait se
débloquer si vous voulez que il allait
dire que il était responsable de ces
crimes mais ça n'a été qu'un espace de
temps très
fugitif
étant précisé aussi que il s'exprime
devant l'être qu'il vénère le plus au
monde sa
mère dire à sa mère en pleine
audience je suis responsable de six
assassinats pour un homme au fond de sa
conscience ça doit être
difficile MAM comme une icône Corse avec
son air fier et ses grands châles de
deuil
face à elle une autre mère Henriette
Alcaraz pour elle ce procès est une
épreuve
insurmontable je me suis pas senti la
force d'aller à la barre et de témoigner
avec lui en face je voulais pas me
donner un spectacle et m'effondrer parce
que j'aurais pas été jusqu'au bout je
n'aurais pas pu alors j'ai j'ai refusé
moi si j'avais une question à lui poser
je lui demanderai
simplement les derniers instants de ma
fille MAM elle n'est pas décidé à se
taire la mama défend même son fils Tommy
à cors et à cris
elle a demandé à aller embrasser son
fils donc moi à ce moment-là j'ai fais
l'effort de me lever de dire que je m'y
opposé que moi ma fille je pouvais plus
l'embrasser à cause de lui
elle s'est levée elle a été jusqu'au box
des accusés elle a embrassa son fils
comme elle voulait sans que
personneintervienne
voilà au terme d'une semaine de débat
Tommy ro est condamné à la peine la plus
lourde la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité ma fille sa sœur donc m'a
attrapé dans ses bras elle me dit maman
maman on a gagné j'ai dit on a rien
gagné du tout parce que il est condamné
à perpétuité la mer s'est levée et nous
a dit nous a maudit elle a dit je vous
maudis à tous mon fils est
innocent bon à perpétuité ça me laissait
espérer qu'il puisse pas recommencer
parce que si la première fois qu'il
avait été condamné à perpétuité on
l'avait pas relâché au bout de 15
ans je VO ma fille à l'époque si vous
voulez la peine de sûrté n'existait pas
encore donc il pouvait espérer en bonne
conduite demander une mise en liberté en
liberté conditionnelle au bout de 18 ans
par exemple je me demande des fois ceux
qui prennent la décision les gens qui se
réunissent ils sont plusieurs s'ils sont
pèr ou mèr de famille qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont dû ressentir eux après il a tué au
Mamou TR personnes mais tr après il en
tu TR autres 3 semaines après don une
petite fille de 11
ans Tomy r emprisonné à vie Guy Morel
entend bien que cette peine soit
appliquée pour lui pas question de
libération
conditionnelle je vous dis une chose
c'est que le jour où ma femme est
rentrée comme on est dans le caveau je
lui ai dit je te vengerai que ça ne
déplaise à qui que ce soit si R un jour
retrouve la liberté voyez je m'en cache
pas je suis pas un tueur je suis pas un
assassin mais croyez-moi je ne laisserai
pas un jour de liberté même dans 18 ans
si comme j'ai les pieds sur terre j'irai
au devant de
[Musique]
r aujourd'hui 40 ans après les drames la
douleur est toujours aussi vive pour les
familles de victimes
[Musique]
Sylvie la fille de guimorel a accepté
pour la première fois de
[Musique]
témoigner Sylvie Morel vous vous
souvenez du jour où on vous a annoncé
que votre maman ne serait plus là alors
j'étais à ce moment-là très petite donc
j'avais 6 ans c'était à 3 jours de Noël
où ben je l'engissais d'ouvrir mes
cadeaux avec mes parents au pied du
sapin et je pense qu'on a voulu m'éviter
voilà ce drame et cette douleur et on
m'a envoyé che la meilleure amie de ma
maman avec ma copine qui avait le même
âge que moi mais c'est vrai que je voilà
je je me rappelle pas le le jour ni les
circonstances comment je l'ai appris
c'est pas facile pour votre père de se
retrouver seul à vous élever du jour au
lendemain la première des choses qu'on a
proposé à mon père c'est de me placer
quelque part un jour il avait été reçu
par une psie et il me dit en même temps
qu'elle me disait qu'il fallait que je
te place j'entendais ses enfants
derrière jouer et il a répondu voyez
vous vous êtes avec vos enfants vos
enfants jouent il rigolent et moi vous
voulez que je me sépare de ma fille
alors que je viens de perdre ma femme et
plus jamais de sa vie il a jamais voulu
voir un psychologue ou quelqu'un elle
vous a manqué votre mère j'imagine
comment grandir sans une maman hein on a
toujours besoin d'une maman après c'est
vrai que petit j'ai été très bien
entouré donc ça m'a permis d'évoluer
correctement et d'avancer dans la vie
mais effectivement il a un grand vide et
surtout un grand sentiment
d'injustice pourquoi pourquoi on m'avait
pris ma maman quoi pourquoi
[Musique]
voilà à 94 ans Henriette la maman de
Josette Alcaraz pleure toujours sa fille
elle se rend chaque jour sur sa
[Musique]
tombe deux fois par jour par tous les
temps qui pleuvent qui vendent je dis
pas qui neige parce qu'ici nig pas mais
je mon c'est un besoin que j'ai alors je
monte à 8h je discute avec elle
évidemment j'ai pas de réponse et à 1h
je remonte à 1h de l'après-midi parce
que c'est là où ça s'est passé entre 1h
et 1h30 que j'étais pas présente pour
lui venir en aide j'ai j'ai j'aiété
impuissante devant ce
[Musique]
drame depuis le drame de bzier le temps
s'est figé pour guimorel toute sa vie ne
tourne plus qu'autour d'un seul
événement l'assassina de sa
[Musique]
femme maître Étienne Nicolo 40 ans après
vous êtes toujours l'avocat de Guy Morel
oui parce que Guy Morel est un homme
émouvant qui n'a jamais oublié que le
jour de Noël
1979 on lui a ramené son épouse dans un
cercueil au pied du sapin à côté duquel
se trouvaient les jouets de leurs filles
la société peut oublier la justice peut
oublier Guy Morel n'oubliera
[Musique]
jamais
monsieur Morel comment allez-vous
aujourd'hui je suis seul je vis tout
seul et qui que ce soit que je peux
rencontrer dans ma situation qui
voulez-vous qui partage ma vie avec le
combat que je mène hein attendez c'est
c'est c'est impossible a avec la
meilleure volonté même moi j'en ai même
plus le droit je je me l'interdis ce
droit parce que je je suis dans un état
de révolte je passe pas une journée sans
penser à lui à savoir au quotidien quel
sentiment vous avez à l'égard de Tommy
ro ben de de la haine de la haine il m'a
volé mon enfance avec ma maman donc il
m'a volé des joies plein de plein de
bonheur plein de rire plein de que je
n'ai pas pu avoir avec elle quand vous
êtes devenu maman j'imagine que ça n'a
pas été simple à ce moment-là non je
crois que c'est là où elle m'a le plus
manqué parce qu'effectivement quand on a
des enfants ben on a besoin de conseils
on a besoin de soutien de beaucoup de
choses sinon on se retrouve toute seule
face à beaucoup de problèmes et là
effectivement elle m'a beaucoup manqué
de tant que votre fils est né un jour
particulier mon second fils est né
effectivement le le jour du décès de ma
mère il est né le 22 décembre 2008 et ma
maman donc a été assassinée le 22
décembre
79 à tel point que quand j'ai accouché
donc mon mari a appelé mon père lui
disant je vous appelle parce que Sylvie
est à l'hôpital et mon père de suite a
dit qu'est-ce qui se passe qu'est-ce qui
se passe qu'est-ce qui se passe il a
même pas réalisé que ça pouvait être la
naissance de son petit fils tellement il
était hanté par cette cette date là je
suis contente parce que je me dis que
finalement ben cette date ne reste pas
associé qu' un malheur on y pense on
pense à elle énormément mais en même
temps ça nous met un petit peu de de
guêé dans le cœur quand cette date
[Musique]
arrive à aussi les crimes de Tommy r ont
laissé une empreinte
[Musique]
indélébile Maître Collard comment va la
famille legof aujourd'hui
elle va aussi mal qu'au premier jour la
présence horrible du crime ne se défait
pas on ne s'en sépare pas c'est
imarcible inoubliable certains proches
des victimes parlent encore de se faire
justice elle-même alors que la justice
est passée il faut dire aussi que le
d'appétence
effroyable pour le crime alors je
comprends que les familles des victimes
ne veulent pas qu'il sortte même si on
se fait toujours une idée de la
rémission lui il est mécaniquement
criminel et même à 85 ans si on le
libérait il y aurait un risque que la
mécanique
[Musique]
reparte tomyo est toujours détenu au
centre pénitentiaire de Borgo en
Corse à 83 ans il détient le record du
plus grand nombre d'années cumulées
derrière les barreaux 54
[Musique]
ans dans chaque prison où R est passé il
a laissé un souvenir
[Musique]
tenace Jacques strujanski vous étiez
surveillant de prison au baomette dans
quel cadre avez-vous rencontré Tommy ro
ben jeune surveillant en 83 j'ai été
affecté au quartier où il était
incarcéré L'ancien quartier de haute
sécurité qui était devenu à l'époque le
quartier d'isolement et au quartier
disciplinaire l'ancien cachot quel genre
de détenu était tomireko avec le
personnel et en particulier avec moi il
était très très correct était assez
souriant assez assez gay puis il assuma
il assumé sa prison tranquillement
franchement frchement au niveau
comportement il y avait il y avait rien
à lui reprocher qu'est-ce qu'il faisait
de ses journé en prison il faisait un
peu de sport dans sa cellule mais très
peu puisqu'il était au quartier
d'isolement donc ils avaient droit à une
heure de promenade et le reste du temps
ils étaient en cellule à part la douche
il préparer des petits plats pour lui et
puis pour un autre détenu aussi c'était
qui un détenu qui avait été un turagage
il a balancé entre guillemets son
commanditaire et il a commencé à avoir
peur et entamé une grève de la
faim et un jour le directeur de
l'établissement de l'époque vient le
voir il lui dit écoutez monsieur cette
grève de la fin arrêtez là et là il dit
oui mais votre personnel à part monsieur
strugenski pour 10000 francs il pourrait
m'empoisonner il d bon ben on va faire
une chose tous les jours monsieur
strugenski viendra vous chercher il vous
amemènera dans la cellule Tommy Ro et
Tommy ro fera manger il était respecté
ou il était il était craint craint je
sais pas mais respecté en tout cas
sûrement par rapport à ces années de de
prison
passé c'est c'est un peu comme un
diplôme est-ce qu'il avait l'espoir de
sortir un jour je crois que tous les
détenus ont un jour l'espoir de sortir
et tous les détenus un jour l'espoir
peut-être de pouvoir s'évader je pense
que c'est ce qu' est maintient un peu en
vie aussi est-ce qu'il avait des visites
est-ce que sa famille venait le voir non
la seule visite qu'il avait que je
connaissais c'était son
épouse
Chantal ils se sont rencontrés avant les
deux triples meurtres de carcaran et de
bzier le couple s'est marié durant la
détention de r en
1991 j'ai été le témoin de ce mariage
qui s'est déroulé à la maison d'arrê
Toulon je vois comme si c'était hier
Chantal arrivé dans un ensemble blanc
avec un camélia la
boutonnière une cérémonie civile en
présence du directeur de la maison
d'arrêt de Toulon qui était le témoin du
marié comment ils se sont
rencontrés se sont rencontrés parce ce
que ils habitaient à peu près dans le
même quartier à Marseille et puis c'est
un homme qui s'est parler aux femmes qui
sait se montrer sous son meilleur jour
et c'est ainsi que leur
idile a commencé à à naître à prospérer
jusqu'au
mariage chantal est resté depuis son
plus fidèle
soutien l'autre femme de sa vie sa mère
mamare est morte à l'âge de 75 ans en
pèlerinage à lourde
elle faisait son chemin de
[Musique]
croix en France seul quatre détenus
purgent une peine de perpétuité
incompressible l'espoir d'une sortie est
donc permis pour Tommy
[Musique]
ro
je-claude Bouvier vous êtes magistrat
vice-président chargé de l'application
des peines au tribunal de Paris une
peine de prison à perpétuité n'en est
finalement pas une en France pourquoi le
législateur a mis en place des des
mécanismes qui permettent parfois de de
contourner cette perpétuité notamment
parce que effectivement avec le temps
avec l'évolution à la fois du profil
problématiques de la personne et tout il
est possible de pouvoir envisager des
des libérations des projets d'insertion
si vous voulez au bout de combien de
temps une personne condamnée à
perpétuité peut-elle formuler une
demande de mise en liberté il est en
principe possible après un délai
d'épreuve de de 18 ans qui peut aller
jusqu'à 22 ans si on est récidiviste et
bien on peut
demander une libération conditionnelle
comment est prise cette décision de
libération il y a deux étapes
obligatoires la première étape si vous
voulez c'est une évaluation de la
dangerosité et c'est une évaluation
pluridisciplinaire qui va durer 6
semaines et si la juridiction
d'application des peines décide de
procéder à une libération conditionnelle
elle doit forcément accompagner cette
libération conditionnelle d'une
surveillance électronique mobile
j'imagine qu'il y a des garanties à
apporter on va devoir travailler avec
les problématiques de la personne quel
risque il pose quelles difficultés
peuvent poser sa remise en liberté ça ce
sont des éléments qu'il faut qu'en
principe on est évaluer avant de pouvoir
décider d'une libération conditionnelle
quand condamn à une peine de prison en
France tout est négociable c'est
compliqué de dire ça si vous voulez
parce que en fait peut-être que tout est
négociable mais faudrait peut-être qu'on
évalue combien de personnes qui ont été
condamné la réclusion crié on pu
bénéficier d'aménagement de peine si
vous voulez mais c'est très
rare après 24 années de détention r fait
sa première demande de libération en
2004 depuis la prison de
clairau
les partis civiles et leurs avocats
tenus informés de cette démarche
viennent alors défendre leur position
devant le tribunal Tommy ro ne doit pas
sortir ni maintenant ni
jamais maître Étienne Nicolo vous avez
le droit d'assister aux audiences du
tribunal d'application des peines est-ce
qu'il y vient r est-ce que vous l'avez
rencontré lorsque r s'est présenté
devant le tribunal d'application des
peines avant même de s'asseoir il a dit
il y a de personnes au monde qui sont
innocentes Jésus-Christ et
moi j'ai compris à ce moment-là que sa
demande serait de toute façon rejetée
parce qu'il prouvait qu'il n'avait rien
compris qu'il était toujours sur la même
défense et que par conséquent les
magistrats lors de cette première
demande de libération conditionnelle ne
le suivrai pas en 2008 lors d'une
demande de libération il invoque un
cancer de la prostate en face terminale
Tomy attendait qu'il était mourant qu'il
avait un cancer qui ne pourrait pas
sortir de prison si ce n'est dans un
cercueil il a inventé le cancer de la
prostate en phase terminale jamais ce
cancer n'a été décelé par un quelconque
expert il eu simplement un carcinome
surun cancer Bénin qui ne risque
absolument rien qui a été traité et qui
ne mettait pas sa vie en péril il a
aussi subi un triple pontage coronarien
c'est pas rien ça c'est pas rien mais il
l'a subi alors qu'il était en
détenenstion l'opération s'est bien
passée il y a je pense aujourd'hui en
France de nombreuses personnes qui
vivent avec des pontages coronariens et
qui arrivent à vivre
normalement MCO gardeesoir en mai 2017
il mise sur le bâtonnier du barreau de
Bastia pour sa dernière demande de
libération
conditionnelle mais pas de quoi
impressionner les familles de victimes
qui elles aussi se font représenter par
une avocate Corse elle-même ancien
[Musique]
bâtonnier Linda Piperi les parties
civiles ont fait appel un avocat Corse
vous en l'occurrence pourquoi bien parce
qu'il est détenu au centre de détention
de Borgo que ces demandes sont
instruites devant la Chambre
d'application des peines de Basia et
c'est quand même un petit peu plus
simple Tommy RCO parle-t-il encore de
problèmes de santé pour demander sa
sortie de prison c'est pas les éléments
invoqués c'est euh le le le le besoin
bien sûr de recouvrer une vie sociale à
l'extérieur et puis il invoque bien sûr
euh les années de prison passé euh euh
54 ans en tout euh donc effectivement il
estime avoir payé son d à la société et
pouvoir euh vieillir au côté des siens
et ça vos clients le refusent elle
souhaite ses familles de victimes que la
perpétuité à laquelle il a été condamné
soit une perpétuité réelle ils vivent
eux-mêmes à perpétuité cette douleur et
ils souhaitent que l'auteur de leur
douleur et de leur souffrance la vivent
[Musique]
également celui qui a pris la tête du
combat des familles de victimes c'est
guim Morel il ne lâche rien
à chaque transfert de tomyo dans une
nouvelle prison il s'y rend à chaque
demande de libération il manifeste son
opposition monsieur Morel vous dites moi
vivant tomir ne retrouvera pas la
liberté pas un jour de liberté c'est pas
compliqué vous prenez un
dictionnaire la définition de perpétuité
qu'est-ce qu'on vous dit pour toujours
autant que durera la vie d'un homme
Monsieur R 83 ans il a passé 54 ans
ouais en prison et pu qu'il reste
jusqu'à la fin de ses jour c'est à la
justice dans pas de justice pas à vous
pas de justice mais moi je je vais être
honnête avec vous la justice c'est quoi
c'est quoi la justice c'est rien du tout
et aujourd'hui en quelque sorte on se
préoccupe de lui de sa situation qui
veut retourner avec sa femme il touche
une pension il namnise pas les victime
et o mais où on va en quelque sorte on
va se préoccuper aujourd'hui de sa
situation on se préoccupe pas de la
mienne alors que lui on lui ouvre la
cellule le matin il il a le droit de
déambuler dans la prison il a le droit
de téléphoner s'il a un problème il y a
les médecins on s'occupe de lui moi
aujourd'hui j'ai P de le dire je suis
seul et personne ne se préoccupe si j'ai
à manger si je me lave mon linge ou si
j'ai quelque chose à faire moi je
voudrais que Monsieur R comprenne que là
où il est c'est sa place et qu'il y
reste voilà si un jour vous apprenez que
Tomy est mort ce jour-là il y aura un
grand vide qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire et ben je sais pas peut-être je
ferai le page et j'irai cracher sur sa
tombe moins impliqué Sylvie la fille de
Guy Morel comprend toutefois le combat
de son
père Sylvie Morel vous partagez le
combat de votre père je le soutiens et
quand il fait les choses j'en suis fire
mais des fois je m'en veux un peu
intérieurement parce que je je le suis
pas dans toutes ces démarche et
effectivement il mène cette bataille un
peu tout seul vous ne pensez pas que
c'est de la folie qui devrait à un
moment donné tourner la page c'est
quelque chose qui s'est promis que de
son vivant Tommy R ne ser ne serait pas
dehors je connais mon père et je sais
que voilà jusque jusqu'à la fin de ses
jours ce sera le combat de ça aura été
le combat de sa vie mais ça sera le
combat et et si ro sortait vous pensez
qu'il mettrait sa menace à
exécution je je peux y penser certaines
fois je peux y penser parce que c'est
vraiment une grande grande colère et
effectivement moi il m'a toujours dit il
est de question que je le laisse vivre
si s'il sort vous craignez la réaction
de votre père ou celle de Tommy ro il
sait très bien que c'est mon père qui
mène ce combat et que c'est à cause de
mon père qu'il est toujour j là où il
est aujourd'hui et donc est-ce que quand
il va sortir il aura pas une idée de
vengeance inlassablement les familles de
victimes alertes les unes après les
autres les instances judiciaires du
risque de libérer
r moi j'aiécris au président au juge de
d'instruction au Garde des saau j'écris
à tout le monde je leur demande qu'il
prennent conscience que ce dangereux et
qu'il ne faut pas le relâcher voilà
c'est tout c'est ce que je demande c'est
c'est mon vœux le plus cher maintenant
une m'a répondu 6 mois après c'est
Madame tobira en me disant que
malheureusement elle pouvait rien faire
parce que l'État s'est séparé de la
justice et là je de nouveau là Macron
j'ai pas écrit ça ça sert à rien me
répondent
[Musique]
pas
la dernière demande de libération de
Tommy ro a finalement été refusée par le
tribunal d'application des peines en
juillet
2017 une décision confirmée en appel 4
mois plus
tard Linda pipri vous voyez tomiro lors
de cette audience quelle impression vous
fait-il les arrivé soutenu par une
canne avec une ceinture de force nous
savons qu'en réalité il ne l'utilise pas
dans dans dans sa vie quotidienne mais
il s'exprime très vertement très
clairement euh il est assez vigoureux
même très vigoureux euh et euh il ne
fait vraiment pas son âge c'est certain
à ce refus de libération conditionnelle
a été adjoint une interdiction de 2 ans
de faire une nouvelle demande est-ce que
c'est fréquent non je ne pense pas c'est
relativement rare justement euh mais
euh ce caractère exceptionnel de la
décision
et en droite ligne du caractère
exceptionnel euh de ce qu'est le Carco
c'est peut-être aussi pour protéger les
parties civiles à mon sens dans 2 ans
Tommy ro aura 85 ans est-ce que c'est
une manière de faire en sorte qu'il ne
puisse jamais retrouver la liberté selon
vous peut-être la situation ne changera
pas il sera toujours à mon sens aussi
dangereux et il me semble que la
décision ira sans doute dans le même
sens
également
mer n'a pas dit son dernier mot il
demande aujourd'hui à la Cour de
cassation la plus haute juridiction de
France de se prononcer une nouvelle
procédure qui pourrait être examiné dans
un délai d'un an et durant laquelle il
restera évidemment en prison
maîtreelotte Tommy RCO a aujourd'hui
pris un avocat Corse pour le défendre
pensez-vous qui pourra sortir un jour
les juridictions qui ont refusé cette
élargissement ce placement sous
surveillance électronique nous disent
deux choses il est toujours dans le même
système de défense il y a pas d'empathie
envers les victimes et même à 83 ans Ben
les juridictions considérraent que il
restait dangereux et que un risque de
récidive n'était pas exclure elle a quel
pourcentage de chance de réussir cette
procédure
devant la Cour de cassation je pense que
sur ce terrainlà je ne me fais pas
d'illusion la Cour de
cassation confirmera les décisions
puisqu'on sait que la Cour de cassation
elle n pas là pour appréhender le les
fait elle n'appréhende que le droit je
pense pas que les magistrats à Bastia a
commis des erreurs de droit donc on se
dirigera vers un rejet de ce pourvoie
après restera ce qu'il a l'air de me
dire dans ces derniers écrits la
possibilité d'un recours en grâce ou si
son état de santé devait s'aggraver
nouvelle demande suspension de peine
pour raison
médicale si R obtenait gain de cause il
ne sortirait pas pour autant un nouveau
tribunal d'application des peines
devrait statuer sur son
cas la grâce présidentielle elle reste
très rarement
accordée Linda pipéi on souvient encore
du nom de R en Corse 40 ans après cette
histoire oui bien sûr parce que R ce
n'est pas que Tommy ro c'est une famille
c'est beaucoup de violence si un jour il
sortait vous pensez qu'il serait le
bienvenu sur la terre qui est la sienne
je ne crois pas c'est quand même un
personnage dont la Corse n'est pas
forcément
fier les chances pour Tommy ro de
retrouver la liberté et de revoir son
village natal sont donc très
minces